oh
vous êtes réveillé où sommes-nous au
village de chasseur de serpents
c'est le jeune schwahn qui vous a sauvé
[Musique]
voulez vous emmène là où je vous ai
découvertes on trouve tête des indices
du la grande à auchy
n'est ce pas
theresa terres de certains
blogueurs
[Musique]
une inconnue a trouvé refuge dans votre
village on m'a confié et épingles pour
que tu exécutes un ordre est de signer
le grand défi qui me rappelle plus ma
soeur
doit être anéanti
blank quoi qu'il arrive
ce serait là pour toi
votre vraie nature se révélera d'autres
tu trouvera t'il toujours aussi
charmante
[Musique]
peut-être qui regrettera d'être venu me
voir
[Musique]
c'est pas à celle du tueur tuent les
animaux je suis un des grilles